sometimes you have a really shitty day
at that point you have a few different
options you can switch on a super
depressing Spotify playlist you can
watch requiem for a dream for the eighth
time or you can play a really sad game
here's five of those now during last
year's Extra Life livestream where I for
some reason decided to play video games
for 24 hours straight I decided to play
a bird story at 3 in the morning now
this was about 20 hours in and the game
does pull on the heartstrings but
basically what happened was that I cried
through most of it now a bad story is
pretty sad but its predecessor to the
moon is devastating
now is probably a good time to mention
that I can get pretty emotionally
affected by sad games but this
particular one seems to have affected
pretty much everybody if you have a
favorite let's player I encourage you to
get them to play this game and watch
them turn into a whole different person
the 8-bit story explores the life of a
dying man in Reverse and cuts right to
the core with an emotionally moving
soundtrack and a number of touching
reveals that feel really genuine to the
moon explores the complexity of
relationships and life choices
it hurts to play but I promise you won't
regret playing it now here's some
insider gist info in order for me to
give you what I think are the best and
most complete lists every time I do one
of these episodes I do sometimes have to
include games that I haven't personally
played now I'm pretty careful about
making sure I get you the right
information and I talk to a lot of my
colleagues who have played these games
but I don't feel like it's fair to leave
them out just because I personally
haven't had a hands-on experience with
them yet
Belova here's Metal Gear Solid 3 Metal
Gear Solid has mood and tragedy down to
a fine
[ __ ] goes wrong for its cost of
characters repeatedly while snake tries
to hang on to some semblance of honour
and righteousness while the whole
franchise is a medley of tragedies and
tragic figures perhaps the most
devastating comes at the end of Metal
Gear Solid 3 now I am about to spoil
what happens at the end of Metal Gear
Solid right here so mute me or skip
ahead 30 seconds if you don't want to
know what happens Metal Gear Solid 3
Snake Eater ends with snake being forced
to kill his mentor the boss who has
defected from the u.s. to the Soviet
Union and is now a shell of her former
self
having given up her child and life for
her country snake but grudgingly accept
our invitation to fight and after she's
defeated she asks for snake to end her
life with her own gun the worst thing is
the plan is to pull the trigger in order
to advance it's later revealed that the
boss volunteered to be framed as a
traitor and have her reputation ruined
in order to serve her country and
prevent a nuclear war in the final
moments of the game snake salutes at her
unmarked grave and sheds a tear it's
really bloody sad if that stealth action
gameplay was kind of getting in the way
of all your sad having then you may want
to pick up a ps2 or three and play
Shadow of the Colossus since that one's
a down up pretty much the whole way
through
spoilers incoming playing Shadow of the
Colossus is a lot like watching a film
where your favorite character dies the
guy doesn't get the girl all the bad
guys end up well dominating after all
you spend most of the game stabbing
peaceful hulking beasts to death who
didn't freaking do anything to you it
attempts to save your love the more you
get into the game the more it dawns on
you that this is just a story about a
devastated kid going through something
awful and lashing out to try and fix it
and as these things tend to go you lose
just about everything that mattered
process what's worse than a game that
takes you down a path of painful and
depressing choices a game that forces
you to make them of course the Walking
Dead's emotional sway sits strongly on
the relationship that develops between
soon-to-be convicted Lee and a little
baseball cap wearing girl called Clem
playing as Lee you become fiercely
protective of your unlikely Ward and
most Walking Dead players will find
their choices revolve around keeping her
safe and sheltered as you search for her
parents of course that's easier said
than done in the zombie apocalypse
eventually you need to conceive that
Clem needs to be taught how to fight she
needs to have her hair cut short and she
needs to deal with death and loss on a
scale that nobody ever should age aside
deciding how much of the horrific truth
to share with her and what advice to
give her to help her along as the game
concludes it's a huge responsibility as
telltale would put it we will remember
that brothers the tale of two sons is
the kind of game that is so sad mainly
because it has so many moments of
happiness and relief you have to go up
really high to get down this far and for
me rather the tale of two sons is the
saddest game I've ever played I'm
actually not gonna spoil this one for
you I want you to play it so badly for
anyone who has a sibling this game will
claw its way into your heart before it
rips it right out the narrative follows
two young brothers on a quest to find a
cure for their ailing father did I
mention their mother passed away prior
to the game's commencement yeah bad
Luck's of these guys even though
controlling birth boys with separate
sides of your controller feels a little
bit odd to start it gets easier and soon
becomes a joy the boys often laugh and
team up to overcome obstacles and it
initially feels like a grand adventure
it's always cruel when things started
tip out of favor the trials become
harder and the story shifts to a focus
on trauma death coping and in the end
doing your best to come out the other
side which in some ways is just as
painful as the
grace brothers a tale of two sons in the
game I'm not sure I could play through
again but I hope you do let me know down
in that comment section what you think
of my selections and be sure let me know
if you think there's a game that
deserves a spot on this list that I
haven't mentioned thanks for watching
this one and I'll have something easy
next week
you